I'm very excited today
to introduce to you,
Cathy O'Neil will be speaking to us about
her book, weapons of math destruction.
Um,
Kathy is uniquely welcome to talk about
the subject of mathematical models and
how they can go bad. Uh, she has a
phd in math from Harvard University.
She has held positions at
Barnard college and Mit.
She's worked at the Hedge
Fund de Shaw and uh,
also as a data scientist
at various startups. Um,
she also is active in the occupy
occupy Wall Street movement, uh,
especially in their
alternative baking group.
She blogs@mathbabe.org. It's a great
blog. You should check it out. Uh,
as well as uh, participates in
the slate money podcast. Um,
and she is the author,
coauthor of two other books doing data
science and on being a dentist and being
a data skeptic.
Please join me introducing Cathy O'neil.
Hi Guys. Thank you so much for coming. Um,
so I'm a math nerd. I love math. Uh,
I was attracted to math in high
school because it was true.
It was beautiful.
Like you can disagree with somebody.
I'm a politics and everything.
About what manifest destiny really meant.
But you'd have to agree on
math because you guys were,
you'd be so careful with your assumptions
on the, in your logical arguments.
I thought it was something,
wouldn't it be beautiful if we could
sort of port this honesty and truth and
clarity to other,
other fields of the real world.
So after I became an assistant
professor at Barnard College,
I realized that it wasn't the right pace
for me, that I wanted to have like more,
more to do with the real world.
And it was 2007 so I did
what everybody else does.
And I went to a hedge fund,
um,
and quickly realized that,
well,
the world blew up almost the moment
I stepped into the hedge fund, um,
was working with the
experts like Larry Summers.
I worked with him on a couple of projects.
Um,
it was very disillusioned by what the
experts seem to actually know about what
was going on.
But I was most disillusioned and actually
ashamed to be honest about one of the
most fundamental reasons that
the financial crisis happened,
which was the AAA ratings on
the mortgage back securities,
which I consider a mathematical lie.
It was the opposite of how I had fallen
in love with mathematics as something
that would bring forth clarity.
It was the, it was really,
it was hiding corrupt
practices behind mathematics,
like trust the math.
Be impressed by the fact that we have a
bunch of PhDs in math who are supposedly,
you know, carefully going through
this data to dump double check,
triple check that this, these mortgage
backed securities are very unrisky.
Trust us, there's math here
and, and invest in these,
in these, uh, these
very opaque instruments.
And I'm not saying that's
the only thing that happened.
Obviously the mortgage broker is
like made a bunch of bad mortgages,
but the reason that they
were able to create,
like build this machine
and scale it to the,
to the scale of the massive international
scale that it became was largely
because of the AAA ratings,
because of the trust.
And that was trusted mathematics.
And it was abused. I'm willing to,
uh, I left finance after
a small stint in risk,
which I could go into if you guys
are interested in the Q and a, um,
where I was equally disillusioned by my,
the part I was playing in particular, um,
in in risk. Um, and I
left finance altogether.
I started my blog, math babe. Um,
the idea was to sort of expose corrupt
practices and mathematical abuse as I saw
it, we should happen to finance. In
the meantime, I needed a day job.
So I became a data scientist very easily.
I should say.
I just renamed myself a data scientist
and got a job the next day, um,
because,
well,
because I was qualified because what
do you do when you're a data scientist?
You predict people instead of predicting
markets at had been predicting markets,
futures and credit
default swaps and stuff.
So it wasn't that much of a stretch to
predict people. In fact, it was very,
very simple and I wanted to think
that what I was doing was like less
destructive than what I'd been,
how I've been feeling and finance.
But what I realized pretty quickly,
within a year or so is that I was
just very much part of something, um,
that I still considered, um, not,
not benign, like actually negative.
And what I realized that was that the
difference between the sort of the,
the havoc that was that was created by
the financial crisis where everybody had
noticed and the financial systems of
the entire universe of the entire world,
we're sort of at risk. And everyone
was worried was that the Christ,
the sort of the, the, the
destruction that was being, um,
that was the havoc that was being
wreaked and the data science world was
happening at the individual
individual level,
that individuals were being lost or they
were being deemed losers or winners by
this stuff. And Moreover, what
was most disillusioning and,
and kind of frightening for me because I
was still kind of idealist, idealistic,
was that these were all being,
again,
they were being sort of
marketed as objective and fair.
These algorithms, um, when in
fact they were not that they were,
their algorithms are nothing more
than opinions embedded in code.
So let me give you an example.
And you guys are technical,
so you'll understand this quite well.
This is my son.
I like to give the example of what is
an algorithm by using the example of my,
my own internal algorithm for building,
for cooking dinner for my family.
So an algorithm is that has
essentially has two big choices,
lots of little choices,
which I'll ignore.
But the big choices are the data that
you train your algorithm on and the
definition of success or
the objective function,
which also includes your penalty for
mistakes, but ignoring that for now.
So what, what, what's the, what's the data
going into my algorithm for cooking? I'm,
yeah, well, it's the, the, the
food I have in my kitchen, uh,
the time I have the ambition I
have, by the way, I should say,
I curate that already. I
curate, I carry the food.
I do not consider ramen noodles
food. My, my teenagers do.
I have teenage sons as well.
So I'm already imposing my
definition of food. Okay.
And then the definition of success for
me for dinner is whether my kids ate
vegetables. Now my seven year old, if he
were in charge, this guy right here wilfy,
he would define success for a meal
as if he got a lot of Nutella.
And the reason this matters is because
over time we optimize our algorithms for
success. I mean that's
why we define it, right?
We want to get closer and closer to
that, that success. So over time,
that means I make more and more meals
that have been successful in the past.
I train my algorithm to success. That
is a very different succession of meals.
And my son's algorithm would be if we,
if we optimize on the tele.
So that's me, that's me imposing
my agenda onto the algorithm.
We always do that.
There is no such thing as
objective algorithm because
the very least the person
building the algorithm defined success
and that's usually success for them.
But there's often other stakeholders in
the, in the play. And the question is,
is that success for the stakeholders
as well? It's not always
it.
Generally speaking,
the patterns I've found looking through
more and more data science was that we
were more and more talking like marketing
these things as fair and objective and
following the numbers and mathematical,
but there were people behind it who are
building the definitions of success,
these objective functions,
and they were essentially invisible
behind that mathematical shield.
A lot of these algorithms
were benign or fine or great,
but some of them were really not
great and I focus on those in my book.
I focus on those because I do not like
vague discussions about what could go
wrong with a bunch of big data.
I want to know exactly what
is going wrong right now.
It's a kind of triage on this,
on the world of Algorithms,
so I focus specifically on
the worst possible algorithms.
If you're wondering why I'm so negative
in my book, I'm not actually negative.
I love data. I'm a data scientist
still and I believe in data,
but I do want to make it very clear to
the public and this book is written for
the public that some of the times
this stuff is really fucked up.
And I define that with
three characteristics.
A weapon of math destruction is one
of these really terrible algorithms.
They have three characteristics. One
is the widespread important, okay,
so nobody cares about the owl.
The algorithm for I make food for
my kids with that is not important.
What's important,
what makes something important?
And he said it happens to a lot of people
and it makes big decisions for them.
Of course, algorithms don't
make big decisions to be clear.
It's humans that have set up processes
by which an a score of an algorithm and
ends up being a decision.
But I'm going to, you know,
let's just put that aside for now.
If people's life's options,
important life options, like how whether
they get a job, where they go to school,
whether they get alone, how much they pay
for insurance, how long they go to jail.
If those kinds of things are
determined in part by algorithms,
essentially mostly scoring systems,
then they're important.
They're widespread and important.
The second characteristic of things
I'm really worried about is the
mysteriousness. The secrecy. These
scoring algorithms are in general,
aren't things that the formulas are
not available for people who are being
scored by them.
Yeah.
Often they are not even aware
that they are being scored.
Okay.
And because they are important,
that is not okay because this,
they are tantamount to laws.
It is not okay for them to be secret.
We have a constitutional right to
know what the laws of our country are.
And finally I care about algorithms
not that are improving the world.
I mean those are great,
but that are destructive.
So I'm really focused on
things that are destructive.
And I mean that in two ways.
The first way,
I mean that is that they
ruin people's lives unfairly.
So those people who's important,
life decisions are being informed
by these scores. They are,
they're getting unfairly
booted from opportunities.
Opportunities are unfairly
being taken from them. Moreover,
they're destructive in a larger sense.
They actually set out to solve
the problem in a larger sense,
usually often with good intentions,
but not only do they fail
to solve that problem,
but they actually make the problem worse.
They create usually a destructive
feedback loop and I'm going to give you a
bunch of examples and
then we'll have Q and. A.
So the first example comes
from teacher assessment.
We've had basically two decades long
war on teachers in this country.
The idea is we have a
problem with education,
let's find the bad teachers
and get rid of them.
And I will put aside for the
now the question of whether
we could actually solve
our problems and the big problem being
the achievement gap between rich and poor
kids. Could we solve that by
getting rid of bad teachers?
That's a different question.
The point is that we have been looking
for these bad so we can get rid of them
for two decades.
The first generation of teacher
assessment tools was really,
really stupid and unfair.
And here's how it was.
Look for teachers,
a majority of who students did not pass
some proficiency standard and their
standardized tests.
Now this,
the thing you need to know to
understand this is that there's a strong
correlation between scores on
standardized tests and poverty. Um,
so poor kids just don't do
as well on standardized test.
That's not specific to the United States.
That's true over time.
That's true internationally.
But what it means is that if you,
if you targeted teacher as if
you've labeled them as bad,
because a lot of their kids do not pass
a certain threshold of proficiency,
you're basically targeting kids,
teachers of poor kids.
So that was clearly unfair.
So it was discarded.
The second generation was meant to be
more fair and it had good intentions,
but it didn't work.
And let me tell you what it was.
It was called the value
added teacher model.
And the idea here is that you can't really
blame a teacher if a kid gets like a
60 in fourth grade and they're
the fifth grade teacher,
you can't blame them for it.
They don't get a hundred at the end of
fifth grade right there starting from 60
so it's just better if they
get more than expected. Right?
So the idea was there was a primary model,
which is the expected score
for each student in a class.
And then there was the actual score that
that kid got to the end of the year and
the teacher was taken,
put,
basically held accountable for the
difference between those two scores.
So if they are expected score was 62 but
they got a 65 the teacher was sort of
given credit for those three points.
If they got,
they were supposed to get a 62 but they
got a 55 they were dinged for those
seven points that they didn't get.
Does that make sense?
Now the problem with this, it
actually makes sense, right?
And if you had like a Google level tests
of this where instead of having 25 kids
in the class, you had 20,000 kids
in this class, then the statistics,
the statistical signal
will be pretty clean.
The problem is we do not do not have that,
so we have instead is a pretty bad model,
which is estimating of the expected
score for a kid at the end of the year.
It's actually really hard to take
a kid at the end of fourth grade,
estimate what they're going to
get at the end of fifth grade.
It's not a precise thing.
There's a lot of uncertainty,
especially for kids in poverty.
Then the second thing,
the second source of uncertainty is like
what they actually got at the end of
fifth grade.
Like they could've gotten more if they've
taken the test in the morning and said
the afternoon or in an air conditioned
room instead of a hot room or after they
ate a meal because they were hungry.
So there's one certainty on both those
numbers and then you're taking the
difference. If you think about
statistically you have to the noise term,
it's called the error term
of that expected score model.
So you're holding teachers accountable
for the error terms of their students.
Turns out there, it's not a very
good model. It's noisy, very,
very noisy. Now I don't know this because
I have the algorithm because I looked,
I tried to get it.
I tried,
I did a freedom of Information
Act request for the source code,
but it was denied me. I ended up
talking to someone in Wisconsin.
This is for the New York City, a virgin.
There's versions all over the country.
But I, I focus on the New
York City version. And um,
I eventually talk to the people
that in Wisconsin, in Madison,
Wisconsin who built that model and they
explained to me that I would never get
the source code for that because in fact,
nobody in that,
in New York City got the source code
for that cause by, by the, the contract,
it was stipulated that it was proprietary.
So no one in the department of Education
understood how these teachers were
being evaluated. And yet the scores
were being used to deny people tenure.
So that's why,
so I should mention the reason why I
thought I might be able to get the source
code through a Freedom Information Act
is because the New York Post actually did
get the scores with all the teacher's
names through a freedom of Information Act
request and they publish them all as an
act of shaming the teachers with that
scores. And I thought, okay,
maybe I can get the source
code if you can get the scores,
I can get the way the scores
were made right now I couldn't.
But here's the thing that happened.
This really smart high school math
teacher at Stuyvesant high school,
Gary Rubenstein,
he took those same numbers that the
New York Post had gotten and he found
teachers that had two
scores for the same year.
You can get two scores if you teach
seventh grade math and eighth grade math.
And he figured if they're both supposed
to be like the final say on whether
you're a good teacher, they
should be consistent, right?
So if you get a 75 for seventh grade math,
you should get a 78 maybe
for eighth grade math, right?
Or a 72 so he plotted them
and a scatter plot,
it looks almost like uniform distribution,
which is to say almost random.
It's actually 24% correlation.
There's some signal in it,
which is why I said the thing about like
if you had 10,000 kids in your class,
you might actually know whether your
teacher brings up grades, uh, scores,
but it's simply not good enough to
hold someone accountable for that at an
individual level. But we trusted
it anyway. When I say we,
I mean the Goe essentially
because they didn't understand it.
In spite of that,
Sarah was soaked with Saki,
who's pictured here was fired after
she got a bad teacher assessment,
50% of which was her teacher value added
model score in Washington DC in 2011 I
should say it's 50% of our score,
but it's more than 50% of the variants
of the score. The big complaint of these,
of the way that teachers were assessed
was that everybody got the same grade
from their principal.
The principals would categorize
them all as acceptable teachers.
So they were like,
we need some spread in the scores so we
can like rank the teacher isn't refined
the worst 2% so they got spread.
But the question was,
is it meaningful? I climb,
it's not meaningful from the,
from the scatter plot we just saw,
but it was particularly irksome
for Sarah because guess what?
She's teaching a fifth grade,
a bunch of four fourth graders came
in with very high scores at the end of
fourth grade who couldn't read or write.
And it turns out that in the Washington
d c a district Michelle ree had
instituted both carrots and sticks.
You get bonus if you get a high value
added model score or high teacher
assessment,
you get fired if you get a bad one.
So moreover she found out that this
school where some of her kids came from,
had exceptionally high eraser a ratio
rates for their end of year standardized
tests.
So she has reason to believe that the
previous teacher is actually cheated on
the test. And if you think
about what that would mean,
those kids get elevated scores and they're
expected to keep them elevated at the
end of her class. But she just got
them. She got, she taught them well,
but they didn't get
ridiculously high scores,
so she got punished for the
previous teachers cheating.
I should mention that she got a new job
a couple of days after she got fired in
an affluent suburb of Washington
DC because most of the,
most of these, this is where the
value added model is being used.
I think it's actually more
than that at this point.
Mostly an urban school districts.
So that brings me to the,
the failure. Okay. Remember I
said there's, there's failure on,
well,
let me just go back over the three things.
It's widespread secret and it's
destructive at an individual level.
So we saw Sarah getting la losing her job,
and at a systemic level,
I claim that the value added model
does not get rid of good, bad teachers.
I remember the whole point was
get rid of the bad teachers,
then we'll solve the
problem with education.
We're not getting rid of bad teachers.
Were getting rid of good teachers.
We got rid of Sarah,
which was just dumb,
but they're talentless teachers who
have quit, who have retired early,
who have not gone into teaching.
We have a national teacher shortage or
have fled to the suburbs where they don't
use this arbitrary and
punitive regime for teachers.
My next example comes from the
world of personality tests.
This is Kyle beam. He was a college
student in the Atlanta area.
He wanted to get a job after
school at a grocery store,
Kroger's and he was a,
he took a personality test.
He failed that.
Most people never find out they failed it,
but he found out because his friend
worked at, Kroger's told him. Um,
so he was unusual in finding out that he
got red lighted from this algorithm was,
which was built by Kronos.
I'm a small,
big data company actually
in this neighborhood.
The other thing that was unusual about
Kyle is that his father's a lawyer.
Most people that are are are
applying for minimum wage jobs,
which this was do not have that are
lawyers. So his father said, why? Well,
what were the questions like on this test?
And Kyle said there were a lot like the
questions I got at the hospital when I
was being treated for bipolar disorder,
the five factor model it's called.
And his father said, well that's illegal
under the Americans with disability act,
it's illegal to have a health
exam including a mental
health exam as part of a a
job application. And he said, well
can you apply to other places?
Kyle ended up applying to six
other places, Lowe's, yum foods,
which owns Taco Bell,
other big companies.
They all had exactly the same personality
test and he failed all of them.
So his father is suing those
seven companies on behalf
as a class action lawsuit
on behalf of anyone who's ever taken
that test on the grounds that it is
illegal, it violates the
American's with disability act.
So that's widespread. It's secret,
I should mention personality
tests are not new.
Radio Shack,
old,
old sort of easily gamed personality
tests looked a lot like this.
Agree or disagree. I'm always
happy. I think your PR,
I think your employer wants
you to agree with that.
These are the more recent ones, much
harder. What do you agree with more?
I sometimes get confused my thought
by my thoughts and feelings or I don't
really like it when I have to do
something I haven't done before.
Imagine doing 50 of those.
So it's,
it's absolutely inscrutable.
So it's secret and I would
say it's destructive.
It's destructive for Kyle because he
didn't get a job at any of those big
companies he applied to in
the entire area of Atlanta.
But it's also destructive in a larger
sense if what we're worried about is true,
that they're actually sort
of systematically denying
employment to an entire
subpopulation. Um, people
with mental health problems.
Um,
it's not relegated to minimum wage work.
This idea of having algorithms
that sort through resumes.
Do you guys know who this is?
This is Roger Ailes.
He recently got kicked out of Fox News.
He led Fox News for a long time.
I got kicked out for like six basically
sexually harassing women and keeping
them from Prenay promoted.
So it's doing a thought experiment.
I don't know if Fox News uses
an algorithm to hire people,
but I'm just imagining that
they do play along with me.
What does that algorithm taken?
Well,
it takes in data probably
historical data from Fox News,
so all the history of
people who've applied to be,
say anchors at Fox News and then
it takes a definition of success.
What does a good employee at [inaudible]
successful employee at Fox News look
like?
Let's just say,
let's stipulate a successful employee
at Fox News stays for three years.
It gets promoted at least once.
Okay.
That's typical for what,
how these are are,
are designed and how they're trained.
So if you think about what that means,
the algorithm that if you've trained
it on this, a lot of historical data,
what it will do is given a new set
of applicants for our anchor job,
it will say,
who along these new applicants looks like
someone who was successful in the past?
And I would not be surprised if it
filtered out women because not only did
women, not, not only did women not
necessarily get that job as often,
but when they did get the job,
they were systematically pushed out by
Roger Ailes and the entire culture there.
Does that make sense? So the point here,
and this is a very important point,
is that we do not improve.
We do not. We do not.
Algorithms are not inherently objective
or fair. All they are doing their,
what they're really good at is picking
out past patterns and repeating them,
which is to say,
if we had a perfect way of hiring people,
we would want to codify that.
We would want to automate that because
it would save us money in time.
But until we have a
perfect way of doing this,
all we're doing is we are literally
caudifying past practices and propagating
them.
My last example comes
from criminal justice.
There's actually two different kinds of
algorithms that worry me a lot in the,
in the criminal justice. The
first is predictive policing. Uh,
you guys know all about the
black lives matter movement,
which is objecting to two
black people getting shot.
But it's not just of course being shot,
it's just the amount of over policing
and uneven policing that's happening to
poor black communities.
Some evidence, there's um,
whites and blacks smoking
pot at a similar rates,
white smoking pot a little
bit more if they're young,
but blacks get arrested a lot more,
a lot more for that.
In fact,
depending on the jurisdiction,
blacks can get arrested up to 10 times
more often than whites for smoking pot.
Okay. So the two things I wanted
to take away from this are blacks.
It's biased against blacks.
And actually it depends very much on local
conditions of how the police force is
expected to act.
So when you hear about arrest records,
I want you to think just as much about
police practices as you do about crime,
at least when it's nonviolent crime.
And I do make a distinction between
violent crime and nonviolent crime.
The problem is that nonviolent crime is
much more prevalent and it is much more
predictable. Think
about it. We have crime.
We have people being arrested in this
country for mental health problems when
they're poor,
not when they're rich.
We have people being arrested
for addiction problems
when they're poor and we
had people being arrested much more
often for low level nonviolent crime like
drug use. And for that, for that
matter, for like crimes of poverty,
just like literally not having a place
to go to the bathroom. And that is,
that goes into their arrest records.
And the reason I'm mentioning this is
because the way predictive policing works
is very simple.
It's actually very stupid.
It's Geo located arrest cr rest records.
And the algorithm says, go put police
where we saw crime in the past,
which is really where we saw arrests in
the past where we saw police arresting
people for things in the past.
This is just much as much
a way of predicting the
police as it is of predicting
crime. I should just, I'm just reiterating
that it might be different by the way,
if we really focused only on
violent crime, imagine that.
Imagine a predictive policing algorithm
where they only focus on violent crime
like murder.
Okay.
The problem is that murder
is really hard to predict.
Like even if you did predict murder,
would you like what Stan like outside
of a house waiting for someone to get
murdered?
Like the problem is that the things that
are actually easy to predict are things
like poverty.
Okay.
So my claim is that predictive policing
is more or less creating a feedback loop
where you're having a scientific pseudo
scientific basis for sending police back
to neighborhoods that are already
over policed. So that another way,
another thought experiment, imagine
that if after the financial crisis,
all the cops had been told to go to Wall
Street and the rest of the bankers and
find out if they had cocaine in their,
in their pockets because they all do
not all of them. Then the predict,
then the police records,
the police data, the data,
which is just a reflection
of what police do, right?
The data would tell them in these
predictive policing algorithms,
go back to Wall Street because
that's where the crime is,
but that's not what we did.
Okay,
so the next example in also in,
in the criminal justice system is
recidivism risk. This is a score.
Recidivism by the way, is coming back
to jail. So recidivism risk is the risk.
Somebody comes back to jail.
Recidivism risk scores are given to
judges when they sentence criminal
defendants. Now there's two kinds
of data that goes into that.
One is a rest records we just talked
about a restaurant, they're very biased.
The second is a questionnaire.
The most commonly used recidivism
risk algorithm is called the Lsir.
And I'm going to show you a couple of
the questions that are asked of the
defendant in the Lsir.
Okay.
Number 29 do you live in
a high crime neighborhood?
It's a proxy for class and race because
that is pointing to people who are
already poor and black.
And, and by the way, if you
say yes or no to these things,
it goes exactly as you imagine. If you
say yes to I have a mental health problem,
you're higher risk. Right. And Oh,
I forgot to mention if you're a higher
risk will a judge will sentence you to
longer in jail.
Okay.
We've doesn't,
I mean I mentioned that because it's not
obvious that that's what you would do,
right? Like if you're higher risk of
recidivism you get put in jail longer.
Um, is a little bit minority report
ish because what you're doing is you're
preemptively punishing someone for
something they haven't done yet.
But that is the practice
that judges now have.
Here's another set of questions.
Um,
have you been suspended
from school number 17?
I'll show you a applaud of just
how much that is a proxy for race.
Black girls and boys are much more
likely to be suspended from school.
But I think the thing that bothers
me the most and I think should bother
absolutely everyone is number 26 with
somebody in your family in prison.
This is something that in an open
court would be thrown out by a judge as
unconstitutional. If a
lawyer said, your honor,
please sentence this person to longer
because their father was also a criminal.
That is not how we do it, but because
it's being embedded in a risk score,
which has been claimed to be scientific,
this somehow has the authenticity of
mathematics and science and again is being
used to send people to jail for longer.
Okay,
so I talk about failures.
I should also mention this is important.
It's being used in more than
half the states. It's secret.
People do not understand what they're,
what they're getting
into with these scores.
And judges are actually very secretive
about exactly how much weight they put on
these scores. But my claim is that
they are most destructive thing.
You can imagine they create their
own reality. If you're a higher risk,
you're sentenced to jail for longer.
And guess what?
If you're sentenced to prison,
if you're in prison longer,
you don't tend to be to benefit from
that experience. You end up out of jail.
97% of people eventually leave prison,
I should mention. So this happens,
but you end up with no resources,
no connections to your community,
very little wealth.
You have a felony to your name often so
you it's hard to get a job and then you
end up back in prison partly because
you got this high risk score so you were
deemed high risk and then
you end up back in prison.
So I'm almost done.
Those are my examples,
but I do want to mention
again that I don't hate data.
I just really think we have not yet get
started understanding what it means to
build safe algorithms.
It's like we are building cars and
just putting them on the road without
understanding that cars can kill people.
Okay.
So I want a data scientist to take their
ethical responsibilities seriously,
which means building some kind of ethical
framework like a hippocratic oath for
data scientists.
I also think that we need to learn how
to scrutinize these algorithms to monitor
them, to audit them
for safety, for safety,
for fairness and
discrimination and for meaning.
Making sure that we're actually building
meaningful things with the teacher
value added model was not meaningful.
And I also think that in
situations where it's very,
very important to a given person's life,
how they're being scored and they should
have the right to scrutinize that score.
Like the teachers,
like if they are being given a score
that will make maybe make them fired,
they should be able to understand
exactly how that scoring system works.
Because to be clear, the teachers were
not, even when they appealed their score,
they were not told how they were being
actually evaluated. And that's not right.
Thank you guys.
If you have any questions,
I'm here.
Hi. Um, what's the best way to account
for and mitigate limitations in a model?
So suppose you,
you have to come up with a mathematical
model to affect somebody's life. Um,
how do you figure out where the boundaries
of application are and how do you,
I guess iteratively readdress that to
see if it's doing what you expect it to?
I mean, it's really a vague question,
so it's hard for me to answer I think.
I think it's like, I'll tell you how, how
frustrating it is as a data scientist. I,
I'm a data scientist.
Like I worked in the City Hall of New
York and I was asked to use the data.
They had to figure out how long a family
was going to be in homeless services.
MMM.
And I had race, I have the
number of children. I had,
you know, out how many times,
whether the children, whether the
parents had been in social services.
I had all this data,
but they weren't telling me,
they weren't telling me how they were
going to use this algorithm if this
scoring system once I had it.
So in particular,
one thing I didn't know whether I should
use was the attribute race or all the
other things that are proxies to raise
or should I d correlate those other
things from the, the, the race.
How was this going to be used?
Number one possibility.
Um, if you were high risk,
then you're going to be put into worse
housing. If you were like, you know,
expect it to be longterm housing,
you're going to be put into wars housing.
If I did that, if I, if I knew that
that was how it was going to be used,
then I would know that
people at higher risk,
there'll be a disparate impact
racially. Right? But if I,
if instead it was being used to
sort of figure out interventions,
um, so that, you know,
black family, they were,
maybe they wanted to understand why black
families were in homeless services for
longer and try to intervene to try to
make that discrepancy smaller than it
would by all means make sense
to have racist the attribute.
Does that make sense?
So like basically not
answering your question,
but I am making it clear that you cannot
answer that question until you really
know the use case for this algorithm.
And I should also add that
a given algorithm could have
a positive or a negative
effect on the world. It's
really tricky. These things are,
let me give you an example. Um, health,
everyone's talking about how great it is
that we can predict each other's health.
Well that's great. If your doctor has
that algorithm that can keep you well,
but it's not great if an insurance
company has an algorithm.
We could charge you more if you're
about to get sick or if Walmart,
and I'm not saying this is happening,
but if like Walmart puts a health risk
on top of everybody who's applying to
their job and says, we don't want to
spend money on our people's insurance,
so we're going to not hire people
with high health risks. I mean,
I'm just saying same algorithm,
different use cases could be used
for good or bad. And so the answer,
the answer is if there is no rule here,
these are decision making algorithms or
decision making processes that are as
complicated as anything in the world.
So we can't,
we can't pretend that there are like
formulas for how to use them and how to
make them safe. They're
very, very contextual.
Uh, do you have any sense of, um, this
is probably a naive question, but,
um,
whether the scale of the problem is bigger
or smaller in a country with stronger
libel and slander laws,
like for example, invalid.
Say more.
Why would you imagine that?
Oh,
well why would I imagine it
would be different? Yeah. Uh,
well I guess the people who are victims
probably don't have the resources to
pursue slim, slender cases anyways. Okay.
I think it was one of the very important
point. Thank you for making it.
Which is that
one of the,
one of the commonalities of almost all
these algorithms is that the people who
are losing by these scoring systems are
often the most vulnerable people in our
society. So they do not
have, generally speaking,
they don't have lawyers to
protect them. Right. Um,
but I would also say the following,
liking, anonymized, anonymization,
which is a tool that people often bring
up as like a way of solving some of
these problems is not
really a solution to me.
Let's think about the medical,
the medical model I just mentioned.
Like let's say I'm Walmart and again,
what Walmart's not really,
I'm a large employer and I get longterm
health data off of all my employees
because I forced them to use
fitbits or whatever I do. Right.
I get long term health outcomes
and I don't charge them.
I'm their hardy, my employees,
I treat them well. Right?
But the point is I can build the
algorithm, I can build the neural network,
what have have you,
I can train it so that when
someone applies my job,
I only ask have to ask them six
questions and I've already categorized,
I've segmented them into a,
into a risk group score and
it is completely anonymous.
In other words,
you can build an algorithm anonymously.
It's still applying it to someone in
a very precise way and it still can be
problematic. So it's really
not for me, it's not about, um,
anonymity.
So in a lot of the reporting that I
have read about this sort of thing,
and I'm thinking
specifically, uh, for example,
the pro bowl get along thing on the,
um, criminal justice sentencing thing.
They,
I haven't seen a lot of talk about how
these algorithms perform relative to,
in this example, just a
judge without this, you know,
score or what the preexisting case was.
Yeah.
Great Point. And I. Dot. I'm
desperate. Desperate for that. Right.
Because the point is that the justice
system is very racist. Alrighty.
This,
the intention of this recidivism risk
stuff was to make judges more objective
and less racist.
And it might be doing that.
Like with all the flaws that I just
mentioned, which I really believe in,
it might actually still be
better than what we have already.
We do not have data for that.
And the Department of Justice is not
coughing up that data. I've tried,
I've tried to get, I've tried to get
data to do that. An audit of the DOJ.
It should be,
it's possible they did exist because some
jurisdictions have this stuff in, in,
in use and some of them don't.
You could just compare them before and
after or whatever and compare to each
other. Um, I should also, but
I should also add that like,
here's the good news,
like if we made those recidivism
risk algorithms actually not racist,
then that would definitely be better
than the current judges. We just,
it's like we threw them out there and
we're just like, oh, they must be good.
Because their algorithms, they're
by definition good. No, they're not.
They're not necessarily good.
But again, you're right.
They might be better
than the existing system.
So in the other examples
that you talked about,
do you have similar sense of whether
that data is out there like the teachers
and you know, and maybe the
teachers, is that right?
The teachers are, it's
like, it's just terrible.
You're not even trying to
solve the right problem.
You're not solving the room.
And I don't think, by the way,
I still don't think recidivism risk being
high shouldn't necessarily mean you go
to jail longer. Right? Maybe
we should be like, why? How do,
why do we sentence people
the way we send his people?
Like we should maybe make a Redo of that
entire conversation. Um, like we should,
if we were thinking datadriven Lee,
if we're like,
if we're Google thinking people like
we should ask really basic questions.
Like to what extent does GED training in,
in a prison help people when they leave?
To what extent does solitary confinement
help or hurt people or sexual assault
like should actually know what these
things are doing to our final outcomes,
which hopefully is a combination of
public safety and the wellbeing of the
actual prisoners.
We don't have any of that.
Yup.
I entirely agree with your, uh, uh, or
was he a wonderful notion that, that uh,
that some of this data is disparate?
I mean it hurts, hurts, hurts,
vulnerable communities. But
despite that, um, like the, the,
the thing you most of the attention
to with was the fact that, uh,
people whose relatives are criminals
are judged more likely to commit crimes.
Well, people whose relatives are actors
are more likely to become actors.
People's lives was a plumber's,
I'm more likely to become plumbers.
And even though it's a horrible thing,
I strongly suspect that someone who's
who is someone whose parents grew up by
stealing cars. No. A heck of a lot of us.
It more about stealing cars
and someone's who's Don,
what do you suggest?
I suggest we follow the constitution,
which privileges justice
over anything like that.
Okay.
So just the way our constitution
says written, send it,
send the police to Wall Street because
it's equally likely to have muggings
culture. We decide what is,
what is against the law, but as,
but the constitution declares that
we have to care about fairness to the
criminal of above all.
And that this is not fairness to the
criminal by saying you're implicated
because your father was implicated.
And I just,
I also want to add that like I lived
next to Columbia University and every
couple of years there's a huge drug
bust in the, in the fraternity's, right?
Like a huge drug bust.
And then,
and then
I followed the Nyp d and they,
they're constantly boasting about their
datadriven criminal justice stuff and
how they peg people as gang members if
they associated on social media with gang
members. But those gang members are
always in Harlem and they're black.
You see what I mean?
They're not Columbia students.
So it's also an inconsistently
defined association
is, so there's two different kinds of
problems. Okay. All right. That's it.
Thank you.
Yup.
So I think it's,
uh,
it's very easy to see that if you're not
careful about how you define what kinds
of success you're optimizing for,
you wind up with an algorithm that,
um,
very strongly reinforces the status quo.
And if we're looking at things
like our hiring practices fair,
then if there is existing on fairness,
we're going to perpetuate it. So that,
that makes total sense to me.
What,
what I struggle with is if I'm asked to
do something like that and I try to not,
uh, incorporate the existing, um,
structural biases into the algorithm,
it's going to be my,
do you know,
recommended hiring practices thing?
How do I deal with the challenge that
I'm actually optimizing away from success
conditions?
Yeah.
Okay. So there's two strategies
and I suggest the first one is, um,
basically a parable. Um, so there's this,
they think all the blind
audition for orchestras, right?
Where the orchestra were trying,
they acknowledged that they were being
nepotistic and their practices of hiring.
So they wanted to get
rid of their nepotism.
So they decided to put a sheet between
their judges and the auditioner so they
wouldn't know if the person who was behind
the cause, she was their friend. Um,
at first they saw the shoes and
then they're like, wait a second,
we can see if it's a matter of woman.
So they brought the sheet down to the
ground and they also installed rugs in the
hallway walking up to the spot so they
couldn't hear. If it's high heels are not,
not only did they get rid of nepotism,
but they increase the number of women
in orchestras by a factor of five.
Yeah.
Um, I would, so that's the
story. And like the character,
the way I would characterize what they
successfully did there is to two things.
First they decided our priori,
what was it that was a
requirement for this job?
How do you assess somebody for this
job? And it was, the answer was sound.
The second thing they did,
which was absolutely as important as
the first thing was to ignore everything
else.
The promise of big data that we get
confused by because it sounds really
convincing.
What's wrong?
The promise of big data is the
more the data is, the better.
Just throw all this data at
the wall. Correlations are
just as good as causation.
Um,
not true because if we did
the orchestra example again,
but we didn't have the sheet
and we thought to ourselves,
we're looking for a good sound,
but we also knew that it was our friend
or we also knew that it was a woman that
creeps into us.
It creeps into our brain.
That's excess information that we should
be ignoring but we're not ignoring.
So the first strategy I would suggest for
hiring people is to think opera, right?
To actually build a model that you buy,
buy,
buy construction is fair.
So build the model and say,
these are the things we
actually want for this job.
The second possibility is use machine
learning algorithm that takes all these
correlations of blah, blah blah. But
then audit it for fairness than say,
wait, does this basically
filter out women check,
check to see if women are filtered out.
Check to see whether they're
filtered out in a reasonable way.
Sometimes they are. Sometimes sometimes
you like, I've heard the story,
I'll go on fee on foot or just the other
day we're way more Asian people were
filtered out of a certain job.
Um,
and people were complaining because
so many of the applicants were Asian,
but then people were saying,
well,
the people who they were more Asians
that were applying that weren't actually
qualified for this job.
Like it's complicated and
expect it to be complicated.
That's my third suggestion is that the,
the other promise of big data that I'm
pushing back against and I hope you
understand and agree with,
is that big data is not a silver bullet.
It's just a tool and is not automatically
going to solve our problems.
It's just a tool that we might be able
to use to solve some of our problems,
but we have to be careful about it.
We have to check.
That's stories where you would go to
a judge or a jurisdiction or a school
system and they would say, oh my God,
you're right. We have to fix this.
And they do. Sorry, what,
do you have any other success stories
like the orchestra where you might go to
someone and say, you know, what was
this problem? And they said, oh my gosh,
as opposed to, no, you can't see our
data now. That's proprietary. Go Away.
Don't bother us.
No. You'd be surprised how few people
want me to see their source code.
Um,
although I should say that like someone
asked me whether I thought it would just
be impossible to ever get
a good value out of it.
Like a good teacher assessment tool using
data and I said I'll never say never
because like 10 years ago I didn't think
we'd have self driving cars but I think
now that we're going to save lives from
drunk driving with self driving cars,
but what is it going to take to get a
good teacher assessment tool is w we're
going to have to have a lot of evidence
that this is actually working right now
we have no ground truth for teacher
value added model. Literally,
there is no comparison to some other
kind of qualitative assessment to see
whether a teacher's good,
a good teacher is getting a good score
and a bad teacher getting bad scores.
It's just whatever the number is is
your score, which is ridiculous, right?
So we actually do have qualitative
assessments for teachers, their political,
because different people disagree
about what makes a good teacher.
But like let's say we had a agreement,
we're going to,
we're defining this kind of qualitative
assessment to be important, to be the,
the, the ground truth. And then
we could try to find, you know,
maybe we put a bunch of
sensors in the classroom.
We tried to replicate that using data,
literally replicate it.
And if we got an algorithm that after
4,000 teachers got almost exactly the same
score using the qualitative assessment
is using this data driven assessment,
then we would build trust that this data
driven assessment is doing a good job.
It's very similar to saying,
you know,
we have this many miles of a self
driving car without an accident.
So we start trusting that car, that
algorithm. Does that make sense? Well,
right now we have nothing like that
in the, in the field of teacher value.
They just want a silver bullet.
That's all they want.
They don't want any prying eyes either.
Something that's kind of come up a
bunch is uh, sort of as an undercurrent,
like the idea of open sourcing,
how you're doing things.
And I can see that like potentially
being really helpful. For example,
now you can actually criticize
because you can see the code,
but I can also see it being somewhat
ineffective if you're still doing,
if you're still asking questions that
are totally beside the point. Um, so I,
I guess I'm curious your thoughts as
to how the effectiveness of things like
open sourcing and also the limitations.
Um, that's a great question and you guys
know that it's hard, um, because if,
because it's religion,
it's relatively easy to make something
arbitrarily difficult to understand.
If you know in advance that
it's going to be open source,
you can just make it
impossible to understand. Um,
and like the other example I give is like
nobody would want the code for Google
search because literally it probably will
not work on any computer system except
Google's computer system.
Right?
So there's a limit to what open
source and can do. But I I don't that,
that's not to say I
think we should give up.
I think what we should ask for is
an auditing, a fairness auditing.
And I think we should think about along
the lines of the way sociologists auto
things for fairness.
So like sociologists will see whether
a hiring practices racist by sending a
bunch of applications with black names
and white names and like similar kind of
qualifications and see whether white
people get more call backs so we can do
that kind of thing to
algorithms. And Latanya Sweeney
did that for Google search.
Do you guys know that
example with Latanya Sweeney,
Google's her own name and
she found the ad next to her.
The search results was are you looking
for the criminal arrest records for
Latanya Sweetie? Then she googled
the white name. It didn't happen.
Then you did a comprehensive task cause
she's a computer scientists and found
that black names were way more likely
to have a rest records act to them.
This ad for arrest records.
Now that's not in my opinion of what a
weapon of math destruction because it's
not as directly impactful in people's
lives, but it's certainly not. Not Great.
Go ahead. Thanks. Um,
I was just going to agree with you before
when you were talking about there is
no easy way to do the teacher evaluation.
I think it goes back to your
point of success, right?
Cause is it we then it gets into like
student evaluation and our, you know,
the assessments that they do on students
fair or is that just a proxy for
success in long term and
their long term career?
So I think the teacher evaluation,
there's probably no right answer.
Um, do you agree? Yeah, it's, it's
a very tricky problem. So it's,
I think the trickier,
the question is that much the less likely
it's going to be solved by some simple
scoring system.
Yeah.
A lot of the machine learning I have
mustard are very popular these days of
written. It's like neural network switch.
Not that I designed. There are pig,
you know, without even batting
better tensions. Like you know,
if you click on the little white button
about why it made it give a decision,
this is say I did these 3000 matrix
multiplies and there's no simpler answer
than that.
Uh,
but they do give much better predictions
then other things like decision trees,
which are much more interpretable.
Do you have any thoughts about how
in the context of these problems to,
should we,
you know,
do you have any deliberately worst
predictions because we need them to be in
trouble?
Yes, absolutely. Okay.
That's probably the hardest thing that
you guys are gonna hear from me today,
but I definitely think we need to
sacrifice accuracy for fairness.
Absolutely. And one of the reasons
is because we as technologists,
we are not the ones that are at risk.
So our,
our concept of what looks fair
to us not good enough, right?
We might have some better understanding
of how things work, but we're like, oh,
but it makes it so much more
accurate. Um, and I actually,
I talked to somebody who does
recidivism risk algorithms for a living.
He does it for this for a
state. Um, and I said, well,
do you ever use race? And he was like, oh
no, that would be wrong. And I said, well,
do you ever use zip
code? He was like, well,
it's a sometimes because it makes it so
much more accurate. And I'm like, okay,
but that's a proxy for race. So
you're basically using race. Um,
so another way of saying that is
if it's interpretable, then people,
it's much more easy for other
people to say that's not fair.
It's a transparency measure. There
is precedent for this, by the way,
if in credit card law,
if your credit card company and so
you denied someone a credit card,
you have to be able to explain why,
which strictly restricts people for two
using decision trees for the most part.
Um, they don't like it, but that's okay.
There's actually lots of things about
lending that are a trade off for fairness
and accuracy.
So Fico scores by law and
discrimination laws called freedom, uh,
fair credit reporting act and the equal
credit opportunity act make it illegal
for you to base fico scores on
race or gender or a zip code.
Is that because it's La it's more accurate
when you restrict know like it would,
it's,
it's actually,
it's keeping these credit scores for
being as accurate as they might be,
but it was deemed more fair
that way. As a society we, we,
we care about public, the public,
right? So the idea is, and this was,
this was soon, like the basic,
what's happened in the 70s when like,
especially in a divorce,
women were being denied loans.
And the idea of there was if
you'd never let women get loans,
then they're never going to be able
to build up their credit scores.
So there'll be credit worthy. So it's like
a feedback loop, right? And so this was,
these antidiscrimination laws
were specifically designed
to prevent the feedback
loop. Um, and we, we need that,
we need that kind of thing.
Because algorithms like that algorithm
I just talked about that benefits the,
the low the banks or the people that make
loans to the detriment of the public.
So we have to balance the benefits of the
for the public versus the benefits for
the private companies.
I have time for one question.
Sorry.
I was going to say I'm in the opposite
boat where I work on a search feature
that looks at lots of queries and uh,
we have a model for English where,
uh, the masculine pronouns are the,
and some common names
are the default to it.
The model knows a lot about that and
we're kind of wondering if queries that
women like we do terrible on or worse or
there's some class except we don't know
anything about the people
who ask the queries.
We've tried really hard not to know,
I don't know gender, I don't know,
income.
I could probably get zip code in bulk.
So, um, I'm sitting here,
I'm trying to think how I'd write a
machine learning model that would do the
reverse question and figure out what's
the most unfair thing my current system
is up to.
That's a good question to be asking
yourself, but I would also add,
and thank you for asking that she herself,
I think that's what we all need to ask
because one of the first questions we
should be asking ourselves, but I do
want to, you made the point yourself,
but I'll just reiterate it and something
that I'm certainly not the first person.
It makes this point.
Sometimes you actually do need to know
these attributes like race and gender in
order to measure your fairness.
So I understand the desire to be
race neutral or gender neutral,
but that doesn't mean you should not
collect that data because then you're
basically saying, I'm not
going to look, you know,
like it must be fair because I don't,
I don't collect that data.
That's not proof that it's fair.
Okay.
Which isn't to say that you, you
know, it's easy to collect the data.
Okay.
I'm saying maybe collected at least in
and for some experiments as an audit.
Thank you guys.
Okay.